Fire of learning presents the tale
of out in from the West fjords.
I'll don and his thoughts are vest fierce,
go author on known,
also known as out in the bear.
There was a man named out and his family
came from the West viewers and he had
little money.
He sailed abroad from the few words under
the supervision of a good farmer named
Thor Stein and the skipper authority
or who have been staying with Torstein
Stein that winter.
I wouldn't had been living there too.
Working for Thor Stein and exchange
provisions and passage abroad,
I would input most of what money.
He had a wait for his mother
before he boarded the ship.
It was intended to pay for three
years, food and lodging. They set sail.
Their journey went well and out and spent
the following winter with story or who
owned a farm and more.
The next summer they traveled to Greenland
and spent the winter. There it is,
mentioned that out and bought a bear.
They're a great treasure for which
he traded everything he owned.
The following summer they
sailed back to Norway.
They had a good voyage and
out and had with him his bear.
He planned the travel south to Denmark
and meet King's fine and give him the
animal and that when he arrived in the
south of the country where the king was
staying, he left the ship leading the
bear behind him and rented a room.
King Harold was soon told that a bear,
a great treasure owned by an
Icelandic man had arrived there.
The king immediately sent to summon him
and when out and appeared before the
king, he greeted him. The king
returned his greeting and asked,
do you have a great treasure of a bear?
He answered that. He did have a bear.
The king asked, what do you, some
of the animal for the same price.
You paid for it. He answered, I did
not want you to do that, my Lord.
What'd you then the king asked, let me
give you double for what you paid for it.
That would be fair if you have
traded everything you own for it.
I did not want to do that. My
Lord, he answered the king as well.
You give it to me. Then he
answered, no, my lord making asked,
what will you do with it?
Then go,
he answered to Denmark and give it
to king's fine. King Harold said,
are you so ignorant that you have not
heard about the enmity between our
countries or do you reckon you'd like
so great that you can go with treasures
where others cannot travel safely even
though they do so of necessity out of
answered my Lord,
that is in your power,
but I will not agree to do anything
other than what I have intended.
The king then said, why not go ahead
then and go your own way as you please,
but come to see me when you return and
tell me how king's fine has awarded you
for the bear. It may well be
that you were a fortunate man.
I promised to do that set out and he
then traveled south along the coast and
east into Vic and from there onto Denmark,
but then I'll have his travel money was
spent and he was forced to beg for food
false for himself and for the bear.
He met a steward of the cane named Aki
and asked him for provisions for himself
and the bear I plan,
he said to give the bare to king's fine.
Aki told him that he would sell
him provisions if you wanted,
but out of reply that he had no money
to pay for them, I want. Nevertheless,
he said to find a way to
take the bear because a king,
I will give you the provisions
you need to reach the king.
But in exchange I want
to own half of the bear.
You should consider the
facts that the variable die.
If you're not have the money
for all the food you need,
then you will not have any bear at all.
And went out and had thought about
what the Stuart had proposed.
He found it reasonable. So they agreed
that he would sell Aki half of the bear,
and that's a king, should be the
judge of the whole arrangements later.
Now both of them were to go
to see the king's together.
So they went to see the king
and stood before his table.
The king pondered over who?
This man whom he did not know might
be he asked out and who are you?
He answered,
I am an Icelandic man.
My Lord and I have just come
from Greenland and Norway.
I wants to give you this bear.
I gave everything I owned for it,
but I have made a blunder for now.
I only own half of the bear.
He then told the king would have taken
place between the Steward Aki and himself.
The king asked is what? He says,
True Aki. It is true. Aki replied,
the King asked,
did you think it appropriate given the
fact that I've made you a powerful man to
impede and hinder a man from bringing
me a treasure that he's given all his
possessions to buy?
When King Harald thought it
advisable to give him save conduct,
even though he is our enemy.
Now consider how fair this well on
your part why you deserve to be killed.
I'm not going to go that far,
but you will leave the country immediately
and never be caught in my eyesight
again,
but you out in.
I will think as if you had given me
the entire beer and please do stay.
He accepted that remained
was king's fine for awhile.
After some time had passed
out and said to the king,
I am now eager to leave here.
My Lord, the king answered,
has hesitatingly somewhat,
where do you plan to go if you do not
care to remain here with us? He applied.
I want to make a pilgrimage to Rome.
If your plan had not been
so noble that king replied,
your eagerness to leave here
would have displeased me.
The king then gave him a very great deal
of silver and he traveled south with a
group of pilgrims that came,
made all the arrangements for his journey
and asked him to come to see him when
he returned out and then went
his way until he arrived in Rome,
when he had stayed there as
long as he wished he had back,
but on the way he felt terribly ill
and lots of great deal of weight.
All of the money that king of given
him for the journey was used up.
So he was reduced to vagrancy
and had to beg for food.
He grew bald and was quite miserable.
He arrived back in Denmark at Easter
and went to where the king was staying
because he did not dare
show himself in public.
He waited in a wing of the church and
plants and meet the king as he walked into
church that evening. But when he saw
the king and his men all dressed up,
he could not bring himself
to appear before them.
When the king went to feast in
the hall out and was fed outside,
as is the custom was Kellgren's while
they still bear their staff and script.
Now that evening when the king went to
vespers out in plan to talk with them,
but as much as he had hesitated before,
he did so even more.
Now when the king's men were drunk,
as they walked back inside the king,
notice a man who seems not to
have the courage to approach them.
So when his men had got inside, the king
turned and said, let him come forward.
Now he who wishes to speak to me, I have
a suspicion that you must be the man.
Then Alan came forward and fell down
with the king's feet with a king,
scarcely recognize them. As soon as
it king realized who he was though,
he took out his hand and welcomed him.
You have changed much.
He said since we last met
and he let them inside,
not when the king's men saw him. They
laughed at him, but the king said,
you have no costs a laugh or he has a
better provided for assault and you have
the king then had a bath prepared for
him and gave him clothing out and remains
there with him. It is told that
sometime during the spring,
the king invited out and to remain with
him permanently and told him he would
make him his cup there and honor
him highly out and said, God reward.
Do you my lord for all the
honor you would bestow upon me.
But as a matter of fact, I'm thinking
of sailing to Iceland. The king replied,
that seems an odd choice out and said,
I cannot live with the fact that my Lord,
that I am held in honor here with you.
While my mother is a vagrant in Iceland
for the provisions I left for her before
I sailed from Iceland will now
be exhausted. The king replied,
that was well and nobody put, and you
will turn out to be a fortunate man.
That reason alone could make you're
leaving here acceptable to me.
Stay with me now until a
ship has prepared. And so
he did one late spring day,
king's fine walk downs,
the docks.
Remember preparing shifts to
sail to various countries,
to the Baltic and sax and
eats to Sweden and Norway.
He went out and came upon a beautiful
ship that was being outfitted.
The king asked, how do you like this ship
out in? He answered very well. My Lord,
the king said,
I want to give you this ship as repayment
for the bear out and thanked him for
the ship as best he could.
After a while when the ship was ready,
King's fine said to Auten.
Now you wish to leave and I
am not going to hinder you,
but I have heard that your country is
poorly provided with harbors and that in
many places there was only open
coastline which is dangerous for ships.
Now say you are shipwrecked and
he lose you're shipping goods,
then you will have little a show that
you have met king's finding given him a
treasure.
The king then gave him a leather pouch
full of silver so that she won't be left
entirely penniless. If you are a ship's
racks, if you manage to hold onto this,
it could still happen. The king continued
it that you lose this too little good.
Would it do then that you have met
king spine and given him a treasure,
the king's injury or ring off his
arm and gave it to Adam and said,
even if things turned out so badly that
you were shipped right to any lose this
money, you will not be painless if you
make it ashore for many survive shipwrecks
wearing gold and it will still be
evident that you have met king's fine.
If you hold onto the armoring,
I would advise you though he said not to
give the armoring away unless you feel
you must repay a very great favor done
to you by a noble man. In that case,
give that man the armoring four it would
be fit men of high standing to accept
it now farewell out and then set sail on
a ride in Norway where he had his cargo
carried to shore.
This was a greater chore than it had
been the last time he was in Norway.
He then went to see king Harald to keep
the promise he had made him before he
sailed to Denmark. He greeted
the king warmly. King Harald,
return his greeting and said, sit
down and drink with us, and so he did.
King Harald then asked,
how did king's Fund reward you for the
bear out in replied by accepting the gift
from me. That king said,
why I would have done that.
What else did he give you for it?
I would in replied,
he gave me silver so that
I could make a pilgrimage.
Thinking Harold said kings fine gives
many men's silver for pilgrimages and for
other things, even when they did
not bring him treasures. Now,
what else did he give you?
He offered out in reply to make me as
cup bearer to bestow high honors upon me.
A nice gesture said to king,
but surely he gives you
something more out in replied,
he gave me a nor with goods,
mostly highly desired here in Norway.
Graciously done so they king and I
would have rewarded you. Likewise,
they give you anything else.
I don't replied.
He gave me another pouch full of silver
and said that I will not be painless.
Even if my shipper wrecked off the coast
of Iceland, the king said splendid.
Even I would not have done that.
I would've considered myself free from
obligation. After giving you the ship,
did he give you anything
else? He did indeed. Give me
more of my lord out. Instead,
he gave me the armoring that I wear on
my arm and told me that all my money
could be lost. But that I still would
not be painless, even if I have the ring.
He told me not to give it to anyone else
unless I felt obliged to repay a noble
man so daily that I would be willing to
part with it until I have now found that
man, for you have the power to deprive
me of both the bear ans my life hit you.
Let me travel and piece to a
place where others could not go.
The king warmly accepted the gift and
gave out and find gifts in return before
they parted out instead of sight as
money for the journey to Iceland and
traveled there early that summer, he was
considered an exceedingly fortunate man.
Thor Stein Guide to send is descended
from this man out in translated by Anstey
and Maxwell presented by fire of learning.